in this section we're going to talk
about the bootstrap which is similar in
some ways to cross validation but a more
General procedure and we're going to
show how to use a bootstrap to measure
the variance of a complicated
statistic okay yes so the example we're
going to follow is is covered in the in
the text that uh it's a it's an
investment problem where we're trying to
decide the optimal investment um into
two assets that minimizes the variance
so that's obviously some function of the
variance and co-variance of the uh the
asset so we're going to have a statistic
that is U look back at we won't do it
now but look back in the book at
equation 5.7 and you'll see there's this
formula which is a ratio of some
variance terms to some ciance terms and
in general finding the variance of such
a function will be you know we don't
have any nice closed form expressions
and that's an ideal job for the
bootstrap yes or you know it used to be
for graduate students but now it's
better for
better better for the bootstrap to do
okay so uh so as Trevor mentioned we're
going to it we have to compute the co
variances of different assets um so
here's a little function we're we're
going to give the bootstrap uh a uh a
data frame um and from this data frame
uh it will compute the co-variance of X
and Y and this formula here uh is that
formula 5.7 um in code form let's say um
okay so the way the bootstop will work
is of course we give random uh samples
with replacement from the data frame so
this index argument is going to be you
know a list of different integers U to
sample or different indexes elements of
the data frame and for every different
index we'll compute the statistic and
the bootstrap collects these and we can
use the the sample standard deviation of
those um estimates as an estimate of the
variance of the the the the estimator
the original estimator that's the the
idea so you'll recall from reading the
the the book on the section on bootstrap
that we do this over and over again we
sample the rows of the of the data frame
with
replacement of size and the total sample
size many many times and each time we
compute the statistic on this resampled
uh data frame and and from that we get
the the samp the the variance of the
statistic boot St there so let's just
let's just check what you know when we
compute the statistic on the full data
it's our Point estimate is
.58 or so and we like to know how
variable that is of course okay so what
we you know for a given sample with
replacement from the rows of the data
Matrix we'll get a new value of that
statistic 61 in this case of course
every time we change the sample of rows
we'll get a different estimate and the
standard error of those estimates is the
bootstrap standard error so let's write
a little function um here we've written
a little function to do that that for us
there are some packages in Python for
the bootstrap but our examples are
simple enough here that uh we use that
as an example to to to to write a
function to do it
ourselves okay so this boot SE function
it will take an estimator like that
Alpha Funk estimator I think is what
it's called um it'll take a data set and
we'll apply the estimator to the data
set and different indices collect all of
these and then compute the standard
error so if we go through this code you
can see that's what's going on here um
let's not let's not go on go through
each line of these again you'll notice
we've stored the seed so our results are
reproducible but okay let's just run
this on our
example so we give uh boot SE our Point
s estimator the actual and the data set
and we asked for 1,000
samples and it tells us the standard
error the bootp standard error is about
009 so if we wanted a a confidence
interval for the U the true optimal
Alpha it would be 0.58 plus or minus
twice 09 would be a pretty good conf
presentable and that was really quick
did a
thousand mind it's a very simple
function yes yes yeah yeah uh all right
so um the rest of the lab here we have
an example of how to do bootstrap for
linear aggression it follows a similar
formula to above um but the difference
is that this function here is just a
little more complicated it's a function
that fits a regression model to a data
frame and a set of indices but other
than that it will follow this exact same
we'll use this boot SC to compute the
standard error and we'll leave you that
to do offline yeah and the boot stripes
it's really useful um it it it the idea
is that it's it's a straightforward
method to to use but it can work on
fairly complicated functions and you can
get the standard error of these
functions yes I like to call it
automagical automagical inad or automaic
instead of automatic because it's just
magical yeah and as you know the
bootstrap was invented by Professor Brad
Efron who's a professor in our
department he's now Meritus but uh he
invented the
bootstrap